how about you'd be surgery over here now
these things we're over there and now
this sir you guys have bombarded my
comment section saying I should check
out Michael Reeves video of how he built
a surgical robot we're gonna react to it
and throughout this video I'm gonna be
answering some frequently asked
questions about the da Vinci robot the
Vinci Surgical System is the most
advanced streamlined surgical experience
for minimally invasive surgery I could
build that
[Music]
hey how's everyone's global health
crisis going this guy can build a
DaVinci robot he's gonna get one of
these golf claps let me tell you those
da Vinci Surgery robotics rats or
ripping hospitals off look at this two
million dollars for one robot they could
spend that on a couple hundred bandages
are like one ambulance ride in the US we
can build a better surgery robot for a
lot less this sorry chasm here is heavy
but it's true like if you look at an
itemized bill from a hospital nothing
makes sense a Tylenol dose is $50 a
bandage like he said is a thousand but
those numbers are so horribly inaccurate
because what the insurance actually ends
up paying to the hospital is a
completely different story the biggest
flaw in da Vinci's design is that it
relies on these clunky slow robotic arms
for movements say you're operating on a
patient's foot you start screaming out
in pain you got to get up to his face
smack him a little bit making shut up I
don't know if you guys saw my surgery
simulator video but I literally was
smacking my patient or weight slowly and
they don't have any travel distance
instead working about the surgical tools
to a rail system that can move anywhere
of an operating table time out I think
the reason the da Vinci robot doesn't
freely move around the patient is
because you want it locked into place
when you're doing a minimally invasive
procedure you want it done in a specific
area I mean like millimeters millimeters
matter that's actually one of the
selling points of these robotic machines
is that they have a better range of
motion than the human hand they also are
more precise and when the surgeon
actually looks inside with the camera
they can see 10 X 2 magnification so
they could be more accurate this is the
homing sequence it figure out the bounds
of the machine by measuring the amperage
of the mode on the motors when they stop
yeah you can make it you can make it do
this maybe not as stable as you want it
to be buddy yeah it's just a prototype
can you imagine if you're getting
wheeled into a surgery as a patient and
the thing is just shaking all over them
and the patient's like what that's what
you're operating on doctor don't worry
we're just calibrating the x and y-axes
you'll be fine I wouldn't be scared
it looks like it's handling small
movements pretty well y-axis X
okay it's not that bad it's fine LLL be
fine we can probably just go ahead and
make the final version all I'm thinking
in the back of my head is imagined this
is how the actual da Vinci robot was
created like someone was just sitting
and they were they were testing it with
ten pound plates from the gym I'm gonna
turn it on oh god oh boy okay for me I
learned how to use a new iPhone app I
get excited this guy created his own
robot I got this VR hand tracking camera
off of Amazon that works super goddamn
well so you just take the hand
coordinates from this pipe him in the
surgery robot and bing-bang-boom
Michael we need to connect and we need
to do some kind of surgery simulator
with this kind of VR technology we got
to do something epic like we gotta
perform surgery on a grape there on a
peach no no on a nut how about you be
surgery over here now this is you over
there and now this is okay this is the
most medically inaccurate part we don't
just start doing surgeries on different
parts of the body and that's why this
whole concept is horribly flawed to
begin with you didn't need to be able to
operate on all different parts of the
patient at the same time that's why the
da Vinci has all these little arms and
gadgets that move around at different
angles because the area you want to go
in then you want to have the flexibility
to move around in that area but you
don't want to be in the patient's kidney
and then in the patient's brain the next
second if you're doing that some shady
stuff is going on
unlike some other surgical systems we've
run a gamut of tests to ensure our
machine has power I'm gonna stab a
pineapple mention the operation if
you're gonna be operating on a patient
you want it like to be if you move your
your little finger like this it moves
exactly like that because if it does
anything more than that you're gonna be
cutting into an artery patients not
gonna do well insurance is gonna go up
for you because you've done malpractice
and it's really a solution or a equation
for disaster what's the term that
experiment was really fun but also
really dangerous Michael if you watch
this video please do not ever stick your
hand in where there's a sharp moving
around
sporadically back and forth I was
worried for your digits terms of
usability in a hospital setting I'm
gonna give it a two it might do really
great in like the kids lab when you're
trying to get them interested in The Da
Vinci machine but they obviously can't
play on a 2.6 million dollar machine but
they can play on yours speaking of The
Da Vinci machine I actually saw that
clip that he said of the grape the
performing surgery and I seen memes
galore of it but I've never actually
seen the grape video - red grape and
preferred green look at that lighting
system
what kind of surgery is this do you
think this is like a prostate byah oh
they're doing a little flap on the grape
is this in slow motion or is that how
fast the machine goes I know minimally
invasive surgery generally takes longer
and the patient has to be under
anesthesia longer sometimes that could
make certain patients who want minimally
invasive not good candidates if they
can't be under anesthesia for a long
time I've had patients ruled out for
robotic surgery just cuz of that no are
they skinny to grape oh that's good you
know sometimes I do that with my teeth
before I eat the grape these machines
the little robots hands have such
amazing range of motion it's better than
our human hands and that's what makes
this super special as a type of
technology because when you have to go
into tight areas into tight crevices you
need really great range of motion and
remember when you're looking at this
with the naked eye it's hard to see
where the skin begins and the grape ends
it's like that reverse it where the
grape begins and the skin ends so you
wouldn't be able to do this but with
that 10x magnification you can go in and
really see the skin come off and be
super accurate wait so that's it that's
the whole viral grape video how did all
the memes start lol equals laughing out
loud TMI too much information beer B
equals be right back ttyl talk to you
later
TDS o AG they did surgery great I'm
gonna text my nephew let's see T I'm
going to do all caps TD s o AG o my
nephew incident you're not a question
what I like you don't know what that
means
bro it means they did surgery on a great
he's typing mad old
did he just say mad you're mad and he
just turned 16 he thinks as a tough guy
now Tom Hanks they did surgery on a
grape my beautiful wife was by my side
throughout the whole surgery my rock
this thing does not look like a grape
this looks like a gummy character nurse
you've been in a coma since 2012 patient
they did did they finally disagree we
can do the surgery you're going to die I
thought I was next in line unfortunately
grape gave it oh my god that's so funny
I mean it's not funny it's dark but it
it would never happen I want to answer
some of the top questions that I get
from patients when they are either
considering getting robotic surgery or
someone has recommended it to them and
they're afraid who does the surgery the
doctor or the robot the surgeons are
controlling the robotic device a hundred
a hundred percent what are the
differences between robotic surgery and
open surgery the difference between
robotic surgery which is considered a
minimally invasive surgery compared to
open is generally faster recovery times
less bleeding less side-effects patients
actually spend less time in the hospital
as a result basically you're making
smaller incisions and at times you don't
even need to make incisions obviously
depending where the procedure is now not
every patient is a candidate for robotic
surgery or minimally invasive surgery so
it needs to be discussed on an
individual level but something's also
keep in mind robotic surgery is really
expensive even when compared to other
minimally invasive surgeries are there
any procedures where robotic surgery
doesn't work there's absolutely
procedures where robotic surgery doesn't
work and we have to tailor that to each
individual patient so when I have a
patient that comes to me for a surgical
clearance one of the questions the
surgeons ask is the cardiac status of
the patient comorbidities what is the
patient taking medication wise all of
these things are factored in in addition
to the type of surgery that needs to be
performed some surgeries just fare
better as open surgeries than minimally
invasive can any doctor or surgeon use a
DaVinci machine any
doctor or surgeon that's trained on a
DaVinci machine can use it but you do
need that level of training you can't
just come on and start using it like
Michael Reeves where you can come on and
figure out how it works no it's more
complicated that you absolutely need to
be trained and certified we'll robotic
surgical systems make doctors obsolete
doctors are humans humans need to treat
humans while there's certain things that
we can allow the AI to do helped us
better identify certain things on
radiographic images help us find
information faster they cannot replace
the mandatory human connection when
treating a patient or the results of
surgeries conducted with da Vinci worth
the cost this is one of the most
important questions and why robotic
surgery is actually a hotly contested
subject remember you have two different
options for minimally invasive
laparoscopic and robotic robotic at
times can be really expensive and not
worth the benefit so where do we go from
here ideally we want to lower the cost
of these robotic surgeries so that they
can replace laparoscopic procedures but
not cost the healthcare system something
like three to five billion dollars a
year also there are certain things that
can be happening in the near future
where we can improve these systems and
perhaps get the evidence to show that
they're better than the laparoscopic
minimally invasive surgery we'll see
yo they did surgery on a grape no they
did surgery on a grape that's why I sent
you the acronym in 2018 they did surgery
on a grape yeah what do you mean my
latest memes videos absolutely hilarious
it was quite nutty you'll get what I
mean once you click on it or check out
me playing minecraft
I actually reviewed some Hospital builds
at other Minecrafters mine
asking gamers have created click here
for that one and as always stay happy
and healthy which one you're clicking
[Music]